sky's royal commentator alastair bruce
joins me on the line now
alastair good to talk to you today this
is obviously a worrying time for the
royal family and it's unusual isn't it
that buckingham palace would make a
statement of this nature
buckingham palace
measures every announcement it makes
very carefully and this is a mattress
for the queen's family
and
especially because we saw the queen so
sprightly in welcoming the new prime
minister
okay
and for
her children to be gathering at balmoral
on the advice of those who have medical
care for her majesty
this is
quite a significant moment
and it is a matter of great concern for
that family and of course for the nation
and for other nations who look to the
queen
as their head of state or as head of the
commonwealth
because undoubtedly this is a
difficult time
and for
the family who now need to focus
on being with a majesty at this time
it is
a very difficult thing for the rest of
us to look in and
wait to find in what direction the
current medical situation
i might take the queen
and alistair
her family we understand are all
traveling but but do you have any more
information do we do we know yet whether
her family have actually all arrived if
they are all actually there
i only know what we have been informed
by buckingham palace and it would seem
that
at this stage with the clarity that it's
quite a long way for many of them to get
to aberdeenshire aberdeenshire
uh itself in
the northland
presumably getting there by
air and then driving certainly an hour's
journey from
aberdeen airport to balmoral castle but
i'm sure each member will in quiet way
will be trying to get to be with the
queen as quickly as possible
in
line with the
information we're receiving that
uh her position is one that
requires the gathering of her family
and and alistair what are you able to
tell us or what what information do we
have about the medical attention that
the queen is receiving i mean obviously
there is the nhs there there is medical
attention available to all of us but but
does she have her own private physician
and and is her
would that be who would be treating her
at the moment do we believe
there is always a doctor available as
you rightly say and there's been a
doctor who's
shown particular care and concern for
the queen
when she's at bar mall he's known her
for years and years
but also the queen
particularly in more recent times have
benefited from a bit of extra oversight
from
the
doctor who she knows from
business windsor and it's quite possible
that
that doctor will be in attendance too
that will be the assistance that as you
rightly point out people of a certain
age do
receive and i think that at the moment
at barmore which is a long way away from
the hospitals and anything like that but
it is a comfortable place to be uh the
queen will uh be very comfortable in in
a room but after all she's known uh
based on her life and she will be given
as much good care and concern as she
requires she's also got
members of staff who've looked after her
equally for a very very long time and it
can provide whatever is required to keep
her comfortable and also it's a place
which can quite comfortably uh has all
members of the queen's family who need
to be there in that they were all with
her actually up until quite recently
and allison we know that that princess
anne the earl and cancers of wessex the
prince of wales and duchess of cornwall
and the duke of york all traveling to be
with her all of her children also
grandchildren the duke of duke of
cambridge going up there and we've heard
in the last couple of moments the duke
and duchess of sussex will also be
traveling to scotland they are unusually
in the country
the queen will undoubtedly be welcoming
all of those by her bedside
the queen is a matriarch in so many ways
not just
the united kingdom but also of a family
and for her
i like for anybody in that position
it's
to have family around the founders are
complicated sometimes but families
aren't what they are and
to any of us in life and for the queen
it is very very important
always for her to feel that her family
are around and i think that
this is a family that has always
gathered on particularly important
occasions and if this is that particular
important occasion
it is
entirely appropriate that all members of
the queen's family share this they wish
to try to be supportive at this time